now since august 8th the day of the raid
at mar-a-lago the angle has been very
clear
to at least half of the country this
investigation appears to be tainted by
politics
now the belief isn't grounded in some
knee-jerk dislike of the rank and file
fbi but in recent history specifically
the crusade waged by the deep state
against donald trump from 2015 onward
a two-tiered system of justice one
standard for hunter and hillary another
for donald trump now fast forward to
present day when the fed's hunt for
donald trump took another turn
u.s magistrate bruce reinhard of jeffrey
epstein fame ordered doj lawyers to
propose redactions to certain sections
of the underlying affidavit which then
will most likely be released to the
public perhaps late next week now
various media organizations had
petitioned the court to make public the
full affidavit without any redactions
but of course the doj opposed the
affidavit's release making these broad
claims that releasing even limited parts
of the affidavit could create dangers
for witnesses or chill future
cooperation and also revealed key
investigative methods
and for obvious dramatic effect they
threw in reference to national security
implications that are at stake
none of that however seems compelling
given what's at stake here
the public's right to know along with
the need to address public skepticism
about this case
weighed in favor of releasing the entire
affidavit no question and doing it
immediately
and not just the affidavit the security
footage at mar-a-lago that was
subpoenaed as well we want to see that
dragging this on through the midterms
with dribs and drabs being leaked to key
media figures we know who they are
like the amorphous references to nuclear
documents
that's designed to do one thing
to distract and frighten the voters as
they head to the polls in key house and
senate races
to me it's also obvious at this point
now on the transparency issue the angle
is pretty surprised that the trump legal
team chose not to file its own motion
for a complete unsealing
aaron blake at the washington post has a
theory as to why
saying seeing the document remain mostly
sealed is probably best case scenario
for donald trump
his supporters and many republican
lawmakers declared the investigation and
abuse of power before having virtually
any information about it
learning what prompted it would only
force trump and his allies to account
for actual evidence
well joining us now to clear things up
is trump lawyer christina bob now
christina thanks for being here tonight
you were in court today when the
magistrate ruled i'm curious
about why
you chose not to file an official motion
or join another motion
arguing this affidavit issue given the
president's desire as he stated it for
full transparency
he did state it you're exactly right we
believed that judicial watch and some of
the other parties actually had argued it
quite well and we believe it was very
interesting and somewhat encouraging
that you had parties from both sides of
the aisle of course liberal media
outlets coupled with
a conservative watchdog group really
together on the same side and so we were
curious to see how that played out of
course you know reserving our rights to
try something else in the future if we
want to but we we really just chose to
see how it would play out well i
understand that you chose to do that but
i'm i'm i'm wondering are you not
concerned that because you didn't join
any of these motions for again the full
release
of this affidavit that you're then
waving possible objections
to the way redactions are being done by
the justice department later on because
you didn't speak in court today nor did
you join any of these motions they're
going to redact all this stuff
and i'm not sure
what grounds you're going to have at
this point having waived your right to
file those motions
well we would maintain that we haven't
waived our right and that that still is
maintained uh you know we need to wait
and see i can't be certain at this point
because we haven't seen the affidavit we
certainly haven't seen the redactions
and how it's going to play out but
you know we'll be making that decision
as it comes out we you know we got to
see it we haven't seen it it has been
under seal so i i don't know we can't
say
well the spokesman for president trump
taylor budowicz
i believe spoke out today and uh you
know made another comment
yeah
yeah about how the democrats have a
penchant for using redactions
to actually hide the government's
deception you know corruption just like
they did with the russia hoax
uh so he's obviously concerned about
this
the that is a concern and certainly uh
the judge giving the department of
justice basically carte blanche uh
opportunity to redact however they want
and whatever they want uh it is a
concern i mean i think that's a fair
concern and something that we will have
to deal with and figure out as it comes
out and as we see uh what happens
uh on the issue of the
footage of where the documents were
stored much is being made of this
footage that was actually subpoenaed by
the justice department do you have any
insight into what they claim was some
big concern about this what they
understood to be
secure a secure area such that it would
necessitate
this nine-hour raid of mar-a-lago right
i have no idea why they were
particularly concerned about it they had
come out the department of justice and
the fbi had come out and seen it
firsthand they'd seen it in person and
they knew exactly what it was and where
it was and how it was secured and so the
idea that they needed to rate it to see
it again after president trump himself
had told them that you know
you're welcome to come back if you feel
the need to come back uh so i think
that's a bit disingenuous i think it's
typical of leftist media to come up with
some salacious story that doesn't really
make a lot of sense and kind of leaves
people scratching their head wondering
what's going on
hopefully hoping that it'll just move
past
sorry interrupt but was it was there a
limited number of people who had access
to that storage room it seems like a
pretty important room right since
they've made such a big deal of it and
have the lock on it and so forth so were
there a limited number of people who
could go in and out
yes or have access to mar-a-lago
certainly mar-a-lago is secure in and of
itself you know just getting on to the
compound is hard and then it was a
locked door and getting you know back
down into the basement there's security
you can't just walk down there only
certain members of staff can get there
and then there's only one key so uh yes
it's a very limited number of people
that have access down there and
you know it was enough to where
president trump believed or our team
believed that it was secure enough they
asked for one more lock at another lock
which we did
and then for whatever reason they
decided that they still needed to raid
the place
and only one or two people had access to
that room to your knowledge
that's my understanding i mean i would
have to check with you know the the
maintenance of that area but my
understanding is very small number of
people that could get in there are you
are you now asking the court i believe
today i believe i read that you guys are
asking for that footage to also be
released correct am i correct in that
um i would have to double check on that
but i think they're uh comfortable with
that yes that's a lot of hours of that's
a lot of hours of footage to release
christina i know you've had a long day
we really appreciate your joining us
tonight thank you so much hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else